alright I'm gonna go to the airport and
pick up uncle Seymour who's that keep
dad's grand uncle he's got one leg
Seymour this is not your port wheelchair
and I'm actually gonna need it back
Oh someone needs it more than this guy
okay got a big one dr. see another day
another life
hello father of the groom you got a sec
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
I hope everybody likes the hotel giving
a wedding at a quality lunch toaster
poor slice they the two diamonds this
bad boy is gonna light up the dessert
table where's the magician
I never hit my children one of the good
things about not being there you said to
call the bills any problem the leaks
Freddie if the rest of the Facebook and
hey why do giggling just fine for a
couple hours but not a whole night what
no it's good moderate in moderation it's
fine
we did you think if ninety-nine cent
wedding and the booze bottles for Giants
let me bail us out at it every father
looks forward to making a wedding for
their little girl I have been able to
help my kids their entire lives maybe
this one
there's gotta be a decent hotel like a
boy I thought we talked about this - I
can handle it we get the whole go sound
like that I do a little okay big smiles
you guys get it together
okay yeah just give me one more try
[Music]